former pope benedict has asked
forgiveness for his handling of clergy
sex abuse cases in the catholic church
however benedict denied any personal or
specific wrongdoing
an independent report released in
january said that benedict had failed to
act against clerics in four cases of
alleged abuse during his time as
munich's archbishop between 1977 and
1982.
his request for forgiveness was made in
a letter published by the vatican and
read out by the former pope's
spokesperson
i can only express to all the victims of
sexual abuse my profound shame
profoundly
i've had great responsibilities in the
catholic church
and the errors that occurred in those
different places during the time of my
mandate
let's go to martin gacdy w's religious
affairs analyst in berlin for more on
this story so we've just heard that
apology from the pope but he's not
accepting responsibility for decades of
alleged abuse and misconduct as outlined
in that independent report
will that be enough for victims families
well i think it's very safe to say that
no that it will not be enough and you
know i mean if you look across the web
you already are seeing the the reactions
to what is considered to be just a usual
the usual approach of the church to new
revelations
you know i mean i think that victims
victims groups had
been essentially complaining about
repeated apologies with very little
progress in
establishing establishing new policies
and basically reforms that can protect
redress crimes committed and protect
potential victims
and this really doesn't go anywhere near
you know fulfilling those those needs
and those demands
now benedict has also commented on
accusations that he lied about
participating in a meeting about
transferring a priest alleged to have
abused children here in germany what can
you tell us about that
well the report mentions at least four
cases uh of what you know in the press
conference was referred to as misconduct
by the by the former pope or the
meredith pope so this is not something
that obviously we can we can say much
about because it's something that is
contained in a legal report and it's
essentially in the hands of
a prosecutor's office so i mean this is
something that you know the justice
justice german justice that we'll have
too we'll have to decide what is quite
clear is that um
you know wittingly unwittingly the pope
did uh benedict did lie or
at least mischaracterize
how much he knew about the case and the
cases in in in the report particularly
for cases uh and then once that the
report was released and there was a
rebuke of you know the pope saying that
he knew nothing about this case or that
he had actually
not been part of one meeting or another
then he was actually forced to retract
those those comments so the fact is that
there is now solid evidence that he
failed to reveal something that he
actually didn't know about these cases
and with that in mind if the catholic
church is looking to win back public
trust what steps need to be taken to
fully address abuses
there's been you know an increasing
demand from
victims groups and i think that legal
scholars and people different groups
among them legal scholars and academics
that had been sort of working through
questions of church reform had been
pointing to which is making the
reporting of suspicions or the reporting
of crimes mandatory
to national authorities the church of
course has resisted this and there are
still several bails of secrecy over the
protocol particularly at confessional
level so the confession is protected by
secrecy
and these are things that i think at
this point becomes quite clear that
the church not being able to police
itself
would mean that national authorities
would have to take
you know this kind of steps more
seriously and into serious consideration
martin gack dw religious affairs analyst
in berlin thanks so much for that
analysis
you